- [Voiceover] Erika plans to
purchase seed to plant grass
in a large field.
She has a map of the region,
and calculates the area
of the region on paper to
be 180 square centimeters.
The scale on the map shows
that one centimeter is
equal to 20 feet.
So they're giving us linear
centimeters to linear feet,
not square centimeters to square feet,
so I think we're going to
have to figure that out.
If Erika plans to cover every
400 square feet with one pound
of seed, approximately
how many pounds of seed
will she need to cover the entire field?
So what we want to do
is we want to figure out
well, how many square feet is the field?
How many square feet is the field?
And we know on her map,
her map has, well a map of the field.
On the map it's 180 square centimeters and
they tell us that one centimeter
is equal to 20 feet.
But if this is square
centimeters, then we want
to convert this to square feet.
So if one centimeter is equal to 20 feet,
if we want to figure out the conversion
from square centimeters to square feet,
we could just square both sides of this.
We could just square both sides of this,
and what will that be?
One squared is still one, but now we have
one centimeter squared
and I could write it like this
just to be clear that I took
both of them to the second power
but one squared is just one.
And this is going to be equal,
20 squared is going to be
400 square feet.
So one square centimeter
on this map is going to be
equal to 400 square feet.
So how many square feet does
180 square centimeters represent?
So I could write
180 centimeters squared.
And we know that every centimeter squared
represents 400 feet.
Or we could say 400 feet squared
per centimeter squared.
And we want the units to
cancel out so this makes sense.
You have centimeters squared
over centimeters squared.
So the actual field is going to be 180
times 400 square feet.
And that makes sense.
The region on paper was
180 square centimeters.
Each square centimeter is
equal to 400 square feet
in reality.
So for each of those square
centimeters, it's going to be
400 square feet.
So it's 180 times 400.
So this is the area in square
footage of the actual field
and then they tell us we're
going to use one pound of seed
for every 400 square feet.
So let's see, the area
of the entire field,
let me give myself a
little bit more space, is
and I'm not going to even
multiply it out because
this 400 is showing up
so this seems useful.
So the area is 400 feet squared.
I just wrote that.
And we're going to use one pound
one pound of seed,
pound of seed,
for every 400 square feet,
for every 400 square feet.
And if we look at it the units cancel out,
square feet divided by square feet
and then we have 400,
divided by 400.
And we're left with 180
times one pound of seed
which tells us that we're going to use
180 pounds,
180 pounds of seed
which is that choice right over there.
Now if you're under time pressure on SAT
although I would be
careful because this one,
it could be a little bit confusing.
But you might say okay,
there's 180 square centimeters.
Each of those square
centimeters is 400 feet.
This is actually the key
thing that you have to realize
that each square centimeter
is not just 20 feet,
it's 400 feet.
So you're going to have
180 times 400 square feet
for the entire field.
But then each of those 400 feet,
each of those 180, 400 square feet,
you're going to use one pound of seed.
So you're going to use 180 pounds of seed.
So you could have done it
without all of this writing
but it is helpful to write it so that you
don't confuse things.